die impfpflicht sie soll millionen
menschen zusätzlich von corona schützen
doch genau das bezweifeln jetzt die top
vier logen in diesem land ganz genau vor
allem weil ja selbst zwei impfungen kaum
noch vor der ansteckung mit omikron
schützen ist die impfpflicht wegen der
omicron variante also sinnlos das ist
unser großes zweites thema hier heute
bei bild blickt heute auf diese
schlagzeile ja die impfpflicht
möglicherweise komplett sinnlos
mittlerweile aber eher der
bundesgesundheitsminister der hält
weiterhin daran fest der klammert sich
an diese impfpflicht will die unbedingt
durchsetzen der imker auch notfalls
selbst das ist noch ein relativ frisches
futter aus dieser woche also dachte
selbst noch mal zur im stade zur spritze
gegriffen und erwirbt jetzt aktuell für
die impfpflicht auch mit diesem satz der
noch für heftige diskussionen sorgen
wird
ich glaube dass also ärzte jeden impfen
sollten denjenigen der geimpft werden
will weil er der im pflicht nachkommt
oder denjenigen der sich impfen das ganz
freiwillig es wird ja niemand gegen
seinen willen geimpft selbst impfpflicht
führte dazu dass man sich zum schluss
freiwillig impfen lässt das ist ein satz
den nicht jeder unbedingt sofort
versteht wir einmal ganz kurz nachfragen
bei julia gesehen noch bei uns steht
also die impfpflicht die führt dazu dass
sich menschen freiwillig impfen lassen
gehalten worden berichtete das ist mein
eindruck auch das war eine ganz kuriose
äußerung und diese impfpflicht muss ich
sagen
ist nicht nur sinnlos sie ist auch
gefährlich denn die omikron welle wird
davon nicht mehr eingefangen dafür kommt
die impfpflicht zu spät also die
infektionswelle wird schon
zusammengebrochen seien wenn dieses
gesetz überhaupt erst gesetz ist kommt
zu spät was bedeutet dass die
impfpflicht bezieht sich dann schon auf
künftige viren und aufkommende
impfstoffe lauterbach selber spricht ja
schon von herbst und winter vom
kommenden herbst und winter das heißt
der blick richtet sich nach vorne und
das bedeutet wiederum dass es dann nicht
nur wenn das so käme um die impfung von
menschen geht die das bisher versäumt
haben sondern geht es um die impfung von
allen von allen die glauben sie seien
davon gar nicht berührt dann sind also
alle aufgefordert sich impfen zu lassen
wo es dann zu lassen dritte vertreter
hamaya vierte fünfte sechste booster
impfung gegen ein neues virus und das
wiederum es überhaupt nur vorstellbar
wenn der gesundheitsminister
eine blankovollmacht durch das gesetz
bekäme dann eine impfpflicht für gegen
bestimmte viren zu verkünden das finde
ich unzumutbar davon wäre auch jeder
berührt und nicht nur die die sich nicht
haben impfen lassen ich bin nie
impfgegner gewesen ich habe mich dreimal
impfen lassen und bin im prinzip
weiterhin bereit mich impfen zu lassen
wenn ich das selbst entscheiden kann
aber mich einer impfpflicht zu
unterwerfen gegen ein virus das ich
nicht kenne mit einem impfstoff den ich
nicht kenne dazu bin ich nicht bereit
und ich glaube es gibt viele menschen
die das auch nicht sind und die dann
wenn das so käme gegen diese
blankovollmacht des gesundheitsministers
in opposition gegen möglicherweise auf
die straße die impfpflicht davon bin ich
überzeugt schafft also neue impfgegner
auch ich würde mich nicht endlos
boostern lassen und ich kann den
bundestagsabgeordneten nur sagen
schaufeln sie den graben nicht tiefer
der das land ohnehin schon teil und die
impfpflicht ist sinnlos sagt hans ulrich
jörges hierbei bild live damit wollen
wir jetzt konfrontieren den bayerischen
gesundheitsminister klaus holetschek der
uns zugeschaltet ist größer sie herzlich
herr holetschek
grüß gott die impfpflicht ist sinnlos
sagt hans ulrich jörges und das sagen
mittlerweile auch führende virologen in
diesem land weil eben gar nicht mehr
klar ist dass der impfstoff den bei
aktuell haben die zweite impfung vor
einer ansteckung mit omikron schützt
impfpflicht sinnlos
glaube ich nicht ich bin tatsächlich für
die allgemeine impfpflicht wir haben
jetzt eine einrichtungs bezogene dies ja
schon beschlossen ich glaube die macht
auch nur sinn wenn die allgemeine auch
kommt sonst würde man das medizinische
personal irgendwie auch stigmatisieren
wenn durchaus offen für die frage wie
die allgemeine impfpflicht ausgestaltet
ist ich habe ja mal vorgeschlagen auf
zwei jahre befristet und dann evaluieren
damit man auch eine brücke baut zu denen
die das skeptisch sind wir sollten das
jetzt diskutieren des könnens parlament
das curt entschieden und jeden tag neu
meinungen neue in der intention und
bringen uns tatsächlich nicht weiter
gesetzentwurf her diskutieren
entscheiden österreich macht uns vor das
ist die richtige linie also sie halten
daran fest wir holen fdp-politiker ente
ullmann noch dazu sie muss sich einmal
fragen denn da war man ja auch in der
partei sich nicht immer ganz einig jetzt
status heute sind sie für eine
impfpflicht oder gegen eine pflicht also
ich sage an dieser stelle explizit ich
bin für eine verpflichtende aufklärung
weil wir haben so viele falsche
nachrichten die im internet kursieren
und die leute haben angst und sorge und
wir können bis zu einen drittel dieser
bisher noch nicht geimpften leute durch
eine professionelle impfung erreichen
und das ist das erste ziel aber wir
müssen hier das ganz klar stellen es
geht hier um einen impfnachweis pflicht
wenn wir diskutieren das erstes und
zweitens es geht darum dass das
gesundheitswesen auch funktionsfähig
bleibt es kann ja nicht angehen dass
menschen die schicksalshaft ein
herzinfarkt schlaganfall oder ein
verkehrsunfall haben nicht adäquat
behandelt werden können weil die
intensivstation folge legt sind mit
menschen die eine beratung benötigen
weil sie umgehend sind das wissen wir
ganz klar auch an dieser stelle
kopieren alles verstanden auch die
aufklärung da sind wir uns alle wichtig
das ist glaube ich ein die wir hier
sehen besonders wichtig das war aber
nicht meine frage meine frage war sind
sie für oder gegen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht stand jetzt also stand heute
und das war ich immer ich bin gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht das allgemein
eine allgemeine impfpflicht 18 jahren
oder fünf jahren das macht wenig sinn
für die impfung selbst bin ich absolut
ich bin ja infektiologie das macht sinn
dann sollte sich impfen lassen aber
gerade die menschen ab meinem alter also
ich bin jetzt ende 50 aber ab 50 igen
vermehrt auf der intensivstation und da
bin ich sehr offen für eine impfpflicht
sollte sich die omikron variante sich so
entwickeln wie die delta variante denn
alle diskussionen die wir bisher haben
liegen auf der grundlage der delta
variante und die omikron war ganze
wissen wir noch gar nicht wie sich das
jetzt auch in deutschland entwickelt wir
haben positive ergebnisse aus anderen
ländern hohe infektionszahlen wenig
krankheitslast und das ändern natürlich
die diskussionen da müssen wir auch
tatsächlich flexibel sein
fdp-politiker android man sagt die
impfpflicht die allgemeine impfpflicht
ab 18 ist sinnlos führende virologen
sagen dass der hologic jetzt ist mein
eindruck dass die spd-spitze dass der
gesundheitsminister auch der kanzler
dass nur noch wollen weil man sich da
schon mal festgelegt hat im dezember
nach dem mann ein wortbruch begangen hat
nachdem man gesagt hat die impfpflicht
kommt nicht hat man dann gesagt die
impfpflicht soll eben doch kommen und
jetzt will man nicht schon wieder die
meinung ändern müssen und sie halten
daran fest weil sie die spd spitze die
aktuelle regierung noch ein bisschen
treiben wollen sie sagen doch doch die
impfpflicht muss schon sein aber die
sollen das gesetz war schön basteln da
dieses komplizierte gesetz stimmt das
es geht auch nicht um politisches kalkül
es geht auch um die einschätzung einer
situation ich glaube wenn wir das jetzt
nicht nein wenn wir das jetzt nicht tun
nicht vorbereiten nicht diskutieren
stehen möglicherweise im sommer wieder
vor einem problem dann kriegen wir den
vorwurf hättet ihr nicht wissen können
dass die nächste welle kommt ich halte
das alles für schwierig man muss jetzt
dieses thema in den bundestag bringen da
ist die regierung gefordert das ist so
dafür ist sie gewählt worden dort kurz
diskutiert dann braucht man die anhörung
mit experten und dann brauchten
entscheidung es kann doch nicht sein
dass wir in unserem land nicht mehr in
der lage sind solche dinge nach vorne zu
bringen also ich halte der stadtrallye
für wirklich schwierig inzwischen wie
wir mit solchen zentralen thema nach
umgehen das wird übrigens auch eine
frage sein bei anderen politikfeldern
man muss diskutieren ethische und
rechtliche fragen ohne zweifel aber man
muss doch auch noch entscheiden können
in diesem land wenn das nicht mehr
möglich ist dann werden wir irgendwann
an einen punkt kommen wo wir auch nicht
mehr regierungsfähig sind das stimmt
mein eindruck ist nur dass es eben nur
noch politisches kalkül ist diese
impfpflicht aber hans uli engers meldet
sich hier im studium mit einer frage
auch an sie denke ich herr hologic
müssen sie nicht auch den menschen klar
machen dass diese impfpflicht die jetzt
diskutiert wird sich nicht nur bezieht
auf diejenigen die bislang nicht geimpft
sind das glauben ja alle sondern wenn es
wie sie sagen eine impfpflicht gibt die
für zwei jahre gilt und wenn dann neue
wie typen kommen und daran angepasste
neue impfstoffe das dann auch menschen
davon berührt sind die jetzt schon
geimpft sind deren impfschutz ja dann
permanent abnimmt die also neu gebucht
werden müssen das ist also eine
musterung in serie gibt und dass auch
geimpfte dieser impfpflicht unterliegen
ich denke das muss man denen überlassen
die tatsächlich als experten da
unterwegs sind diese einschätzungen
vorzunehmen ich glaube und das ist meine
politische einschätzung dass wir aus
dieser endlosschleife dieser pandemie
nur rauskommen wenn wir höhere impfungen
haben das ist doch auch kein wortbruch
wenn sie das vor so gesagt haben wir
haben einfach eine andere einschätzung
ich war immer der meinung wir müssen die
menschen doch argumente überzeugen das
bin ich heute noch aber wir schaffen es
doch nicht wenn wir ehrlich sind
deswegen muss man doch auch mal eine
meinung nach justieren können und jetzt
sind die gefragt die als experten
unterwegs sind wie gerade der kollege
der infektiologie ist es zu beurteilen
und zu sagen was sind die richtigen
parameter für diese impfnachweis pflicht
wir hatten ja schon im nachweispflicht
nach bei masern und bei anderen themen
das ist ja jetzt nicht total was neues
und wir sind in einer ausnahmesituation
die pandemie ist immer noch da wir haben
immer noch in bayern einen
katastrophenfall als dieser nicht so
dass das alles jetzt aus spaß und jux
und tollerei ist dass man jetzt über
eine impfpflicht redet
gerade auch den gesundheitsminister
gesehen der gesagt hat er setzt darauf
dass die impfpflicht zu mehr
freiwilligkeit bei denen führen würde
die derzeit noch ungeimpft sind fragen
sie haben sie diesen satz verstanden und
wenn ja glauben sie wirklich dass die
impfpflicht dazu führen würde dass dann
menschen die sich bisher nicht impfen
lassen wollen sagen ach eigentlich eine
gute idee jetzt geh mal freiwillig zum
arzt machen termin aus glauben sie daran
also ich glaube wir werden zum einen mit
dem impfstoff nowaks der ja leider erst
im februar kommt noch einiges erreichen
können da bin ich der felsenfest
überzeugt wenn wir den speziell auch
medizinischen pflegerischen personal
geben und zum einen wird der ein oder
andere sagen jetzt ist die impfpflicht
da jetzt mache ich dass ich verliere
auch mein gesicht jetzt nicht weil es
gibt eine verpflichtung ich denke dass
es damit gemeinsamen das glaube ich die
intention steckt dahinter dass menschen
diesen schritt jetzt noch gehen und
sagen okay jetzt gibt es einfach dieses
thema und jetzt mach ich es wie viele es
sind weiß ich nicht